[Music]
welcome back to cbs morning's britain's
prince andrew faces possible trial in
connection with his former friend
jeffrey epstein a u.s judge has turned
down andrew's request to throw out a
lawsuit filed against him by one of
epstein's alleged sex trafficking
victims the prince's lawyer said this
morning they have no comment on the
ruling holly williams is at windsor
castle outside london near andrew's main
residence with a potential risk to him
and to the royal family holly good
morning
good morning while the british monarchy
this nearly one thousand year old
institution has never seen anything
quite like this the queen's second son
said to be her favorite son does still
have legal options but all of them could
prove to be expensive both financially
and in terms of his reputation
this case is going forward and it's
going forward now cbs news legal analyst
ricky clemen says this may have been
prince andrews last chance to get this
civil suit dismissed the last thing
that prince andrew wants and that the
royal family want is further publicity
in this degrading saga
his accuser is virginia jafree who
claims the prince sexually assaulted her
on multiple occasions when she was a
teenager prince andrew should be
panicking he needs to be held
accountable he denies it has never been
charged with a crime and says he has no
recollection of ever meeting her despite
this image of them together
jeffrey alleges she was trafficked to
the prince by jeffrey epstein and
lawyers for prince andrew argued a
settlement she reached with epstein for
half a million dollars in 2009 shielded
the british royal from legal action but
the judge ruled the case can proceed as
a uk resident prince andrew could refuse
to cooperate we never had any sort of
sexual contact whatever though that
tactic may be disastrous
ultimately
if he refuses to give evidence if he
does not participate in this case
what would happen is the plaintiff would
move for a default judgment against him
for 500 000 a million 10 million
whatever it would happen to be
he was once regarded as a handsome
playboy prince but his name is now
indelibly stained by his friendships
with convicted sex offenders epstein and
glenn maxwell
on the streets of windsor the town
dominated by the royal castle some
people are angry everybody feels for the
queen a lot in this circumstance
it is her son and of course she's going
to want to protect him and her family
and their privacy
but that doesn't mean you get a get out
of jail free card either
ricky clemen believes prince andrew's
best option is to try to reach a
settlement with virginia defray stopping
the case going any further but that
depends on her
i think virginia dufrese is determined
to have her day in court but still
there's always a magic number for most
people there is an offer that cannot be
refused unless the money means
absolutely nothing to you and perhaps
for virginia du faye perhaps the money
is irrelevant
virginia dufrese lawyer said last night
that he believes she is not interested
in a purely financial settlement
suggesting she may only agree to settle
this lawsuit if prince andrew
acknowledges he's done something wrong
nate
and time will tell if he will yes
hollywood and repeatedly though
we've interviewed her she said
repeatedly that she wishes he would
apologize i don't think that it's about
money for her i really don't it's not
backing down you're right about that
holly williams and windsor thank you